and while the biden administration
refuses to take on china
parents all over the country are
standing up to the threat of critical
race theory
uh it's taking over kids education my
next guest went viral
and he had a brilliant takedown of the
toxic ideology at an illinois
school board meeting watch when you talk
about critical race theory which is
pretty much going to be teaching kids
how to hate each other
how to dislike each other that's pretty
much what it's like that's pretty much
all of character is pretty much what
it's going to all come down to
two medical degrees no mom no dad in the
house work my way through college
sat there and hustled my butt off to get
through cops you don't tell me somebody
looked like all your white folks
kept me from doing that joining me now
the man you just saw ty smith illinois
dad
and radio host ty now during that
meeting
he not only called out the critical race
theory hoax but also called out the
people
pushing it for ignoring
you know things that are actually very
positive for black communities explain
that
well the thing is is that most of the
time you have people in a room and it
seems like everybody just kind of jump
on board
what's going on they give no thought to
it they ask no questions just said oh
if this person says it's right if this
person says it well this must be right
so let's
everybody jump on board and while i sat
in that room i looked around and i
realized i was the only black person in
there and i had all these white people
up telling
talking about the black experience and
none of them looked like me in that room
i'm trying to figure out how do they
know this because i've never seen
any of these folks in the areas that i
grew up in and live but yet to be on the
outside like they were
doing all this virtue signaling and all
that i just called i caught
i was just so worked up because i was
calling bs on because the very thing
that they were talking about i was that
kid in the ghetto i was that kid in the
hood
and i'm like no what y'all talking about
that you guys weren't the problem
the issue that a lot of black people
have right now is swallowing a hard
reappeal
and that's to realize that we absolutely
are the biggest problem and the biggest
threat to us
progressing not white people well we
were just talking about this in the
previous segment which is
of course the crime in the inner city
now that we have a defund police
movement we have demonization of police
are bad you know
not diverse whatever the concern is and
this is leading to the deaths
of more minorities but the media doesn't
want to talk about that that's not a
convenient narrative
and you'd rather talk about how
everyone's so racist in the schools and
turn the kids against each other
right they got you looking at they got
you they got you focused on something
else while something else behind your
back is going on
everything that's happening right now
again no i don't care if anybody wants
to agree with me or not i live this
stuff
the biggest threat to me when i was
growing up was somebody that looked
exactly like me
i never had no threat from any white
police officer or any white person
whatsoever and to get myself through
school like i did
there was no system there that they
claimed that was there i'm sorry i'm
just calling like is now
back in the day slave days and you know
pre uh civil rights movement
i get that but in today's world
absolutely not
all they're doing is keep on handing
folks walkers
why are they doing it why are they
pushing this on the kids
because they want them to believe that
they can't achieve anything they want to
just make it all about their race they
can't do anything and to me i
told them you know it's going to keep
you there the very person that claimed
that they're helping you if you keep on
handing a person a walker and saying
this is me helping you that person will
never become independent one of my
degrees in physical therapy our number
one goal
is to get our patients independent and
as they become better and stronger and
uh more progressing in their uh the set
things that we have set for them the set
programs
we take the assisted device away because
they're becoming more independent which
means they can do things on their own
but what we get right now from the
government is they just keep on handing
people walkers saying
this is me helping you see look how good
we are this is us helping you but having
no idea is damaging you because you're
going to remain disabled
and dependent on the government and that
the only hit you hit the threshold the
ceiling and you can't go any further if
you're dependent on the government
hey ty you you shook it up you shook it
up keep shaking it off
it was great to see you tonight thanks
so much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else